I just wanted to mention something here
which I'm certain most of you are aware
but nobody has really mentioned it
explicitly so I'm going to do it anyways
who a few knows Old English Maps
they're always those areas where you
don't know what it's happening and this
is usually the part where they say there
are be dragons so if you just download
from so I could learn any image that's
not a good resolution and you have the
spots wages honestly you don't have any
data and you don't know what happened
there if you write any sort of
recommended system or whatever it will
tell you what the point there is but
truth is you have never seen a point
there
and during World War two
Abraham Walt had a related problem so he
was supposed to increase the armor for I
don't know which planes I think that's
some sort of planes okay
bombers anyways though there you can see
whether returning bomb bus got hit so
they usually increase the armor there
and he had the idea well maybe we should
just increase the armor where the bomber
was not hit because the planes took a
hit there they were just went straight
down so whenever you have data you
actually want to sample it properly and
you also just want to see where where am
I in my data space where I am I'm a
sampling space and I guess you could do
a whole conference on it so I probably
will not find a good solution five
minutes but how to circumvent your
dragons um you could for the easiest
part just run if statements on all your
inputs if you have an easy classifier
you could do high distance high
dimension distance comparisons you could
do a gardens as we learned in one of the
talks today and you can also if you get
out of the data science life you can try
to get more data points like the
prominent ones so I'm supposed to tell
when our machines fail so I'm trying to
convince my boss that we could just let
some of them crash and then we
really good data we have not agreed on
that yet we yesterday we heard the
suggestion use small diverse teams are
when we were debating the problem in the
Amazon selector which basically
automatically checked the CVS and did a
pre selection for the hiring stuff maybe
you should just tell that every once in
a while you just let one person slip
through and random and that again of
course would create an ethical problem
and at this point I'm quite happy that I
work with machine data but then you
would have a person that we would not
know if they perform well or not but it
would certainly be a new point on your
data map and the last point I want to
make because for example if you create a
few those your classifier and cat and
dog images and you show an elephant and
of course the rule say either cat or dog
having a background in computational
neuroscience who else here has
computational neuroscience ever done yay
maybe we also just need more biological
motivation from neural nets because
technically they should be capable of
and at the moment we just recreated the
smallest part we have an idea of how we
recreate it in Iran and then we stack
them together and ways we think that are
correct maybe should get more ideas on
that final slide I found this from Peter
Byrne who founded from Andrew capaci and
I suppose it was a good idea amount less
to sleep over and the data set and the
algorithm and basically having more data
is always a good idea if possible thank
you
[Applause]